hallo leute ich ist wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu einem neuen look
bahn video
ich habe in den kommentaren oft genug
gelesen dass es nicht machbar heißt
sondern muss dann sag ich jetzt richtig
bock bahn mgbahn weil ich lese halt
immer nur bei den amerikanern oder die
die englisch sprechen dann halt immer
macbeth ich mal was mitbringen heißt
aber anscheinend heißes mig bank also
willkommen beim neuen mobilen video ja
ihr wollt bestimmt alle wissen was ich
hier wunderbares heute habe und zwar ist
das eine schoko wien eine schoko wiener
torte und eine schoko wiener torte ich
weiß nicht mandeln sind drauf und ich
glaube eine mandel creme und zu trinken
habe ich meine lieblings schwarztee
einen gray
ich habe gerade gedacht dass ich meine
haare zum ersten mal spoiler aber dass
der block kam ja schon anleihen aber
vielleicht haben es andere noch nicht
gesehen werden du den block noch nicht
gesehen hast dann ist das jetzt eine
überraschung für dich
ich habe graue haare
also wenn man es richtig erkennt dann
sind graue haare und sie sehen aber auch
wie schwarz und ich sehe tatsächlich
gerade ein bisschen aus wie kylie jenner
fällt mir auf also nicht dass ich so ein
selbstbewusstsein habt ihr keine denn
aussehe aber mit dem lippenstift der ich
mir übrigens heute neu gekauft habe ja
ich glaube manchmal hat er auch so kurze
schwarze haare
ok ich probiere mal ein stück
okay er schmeckt genauso schokoladig wie
er aussieht
ohne witz ja warum mache ich schon
wieder ein ruck bank video weil es
vielen von euch gefallen hat um jetzt
aufgefallen ich fand's cool einfach mal
so zu reden ohne irgendwie text zu haben
und als in so viele meinten von euch so
ja supergeil machen mach mal mehr bin
ich schön muss ja nicht jeder anschauen
ist ja nicht nur weil du mich abonniert
hast musst du dir nicht jedes video
anschauen
besonders nicht wenn du leute essen wenn
du nicht läuten beim essen zu gucken
kannst dann kann ich das natürlich
verstehen dass du das nicht gerne
schaust du kleine maus ach so ich hab
guten hier bei meinem blog gesehen meine
eltern waren zu besuch mit meinem bruder
und da hatten wir gucken gekauft ich hab
mich selbst gebacken weil ich super faul
bin und manchmal gerne einfach den kauf
hat sie selbst zu machen aber das ist
hier haben wir nämlich in berlin in
friedrich sein sohn richtig kleine
bäcker oder so einem restaurant der
sogar kuchen macht und deswegen darf man
auch mal kaufen statt backen
es könnte so neues motto sein kaufen
statt backen und ich verspreche ich mit
vollem mund urin
ich verspreche dass ich nicht schwarze
eine sache wir haben viele nicht
philippen paar haben gesagt die spitze
ich versuche dass das video nicht zu
lange ist eine halbe stunde war wirklich
eine halbe stunde ist zu lange ich weiß
aber das ist ja nicht so viel wie sushi
ich weiß nicht ob ich das ganze stück
schaffe wir sehen die fans aber so cool
für mich so gemütlich haben sie an diese
sky draußen und ich war schon draußen
aber schon gearbeitet und hier setze ich
mich hin und es mit euch ein stück
kuchen seid eingeladen wodurch ein stück
kuchen
das hab ich etwas schönes es hat
definitiv was schönes und für die leute
die es nicht wussten und im blog das
erste mal gesehen haben ja mein bruder
sitzt im rollstuhl
also ich plane demnächst mal ein video
zusammen mit ihm zu machen weiß
eigentlich ganz interessante geschichte
finde also ich finde das ist eine
geschichte die kann man einfach mal
erzählen und ich habe ein portal das
portal
ich habe eine plattform auf der ich das
erzählen kann und ich würde die einfach
gerne euch mal erzählen die geschichte
von meinem bruder und dazu wird
wahrscheinlich noch mal ein video geben
ich habe ich ihn gefragt hier mit dem
sport dazu lust hätte und er war sofort
feuer und flamme wenn man das noch so
sagen kann
ich glaube nicht sagt man noch feuer und
flamme ich bin feuer und flamme kochen
schaut euch den anleger das ist ein
riesen stück basiert auf der kamera gar
nicht mal so groß also das ist ein
riesen bombastischen stück welches thema
ich heute auch noch besprechen möchte
mit euch und ich weiß es hängt euch
wahrscheinlich schon aus den ohren raus
das thema youtube
ja denn dazu sieht man ja momentan weiß
ich nicht ich glaube jeder youtuber
macht momentan dazu ein video
nein ich wollte ich keins machen weil
ich wollte gar nicht ansprechen weil das
ist es hat so viel mit suggestiver
wahrnehmung zu tun wenn ihr nicht wisst
was es ist suggestive warnen so tiefe
suggestive wahrnehmung ist wenn du etwas
weiß ich beispiel meine schwester war
schwanger und zu der zeit habe ich nur
noch babys gesehen und dachte die ganze
welt besteht nur noch aus babys und
jeder kriegt nur noch babys und das ist
weil du halt
darauf eines was ich meine ist das heißt
eigentlich erklärt so und dadurch dass
jetzt ein paar youtuber dieses problem
haben mit youtube das nicht willst der
algorithmus stimmten bisher spenden
bisher in die abo box spielend und ja es
verändert sich gerade viel und da haben
youtube juli zeit zum beispiel und die
haben video dazu gemacht und bei den
spinnen zeit und jetzt machen halt so
viele youtube auch ein video dazu und
dadurch kommt es halt dem zuschauer
wirklich so rüber als ob das halt das
problem bisschen größer ist als es
eigentlich ist für ein einzelner
youtuber ist es richtig scheiße aber es
gibt halt auch youtube aber das habe ich
so beobachteten so ein paar die sich
darüber beschwert haben wo ich halt
geguckt habe wie denn die aufruf zahlen
davor waren und da ist halt nicht viel
anders nicht glaube und genau da ist es
halt diese subjektive wahrnehmung
einerseits der zuschauer denkt es sei
ein riesenproblem ist aber auch der
youtuber dadurch dass sich so viele
beschweren sieht er plötzlich dass auf
seinem kanal ist schlechter läuft obwohl
es gar nicht vielleicht stimmen könnte
obwohl es könnte halt sein dass es
einfach so wie immer läuft nur dadurch
dass er denkt dass es gibt gar kein
problem sieht er bei sich plötzlich auch
ein problem
ja und analysiert seinen kanal dann halt
einfach falsch oder oder das problem
oder ob er überhaupt ein problem hat
[Musik]
deswegen macht euch mal keine sorgen
das wichtigste was er machen können als
zuschauer ich bin ja auch zuschauer ich
bin ja auch nicht schaue mir auch andere
videos an ist euren youtuber weiterhin
zu supporten ab und zu mal bei den
leuten die wirklich schauen wollt wahl
in die abo boxerin die in den kanal
rhein zu gucken und zu gucken ob da
wirklich ein videos was übersehen haben
und wenn ihr die leute supporten volt
nach dem blog ich kann verstehen dass
man werbung nicht mag ich kann es
verstehen wirklich
und wenn wenn man wieder einschaltet und
da irgendwie fünf werbung eingeschaltet
sind kann hier irgendwo verstehen dass
man den bürger an macht hier dieser
montana ab und montana black hat dazu
gehört auch ein video gemacht habe ich
vorhin gesehen dass er ihr baby und
julian machen irgendwie fünf werbung
rein dann gab es da noch einen anderen
minecraft da der 18 werbung rein gemacht
hat weil du ab zehn minuten in ein video
länger als zehn minuten ist dann darfst
du mehr werbung machen
mir ist aufgefallen dass letzte markt
bringen hatte 30 minuten und aber eine
werbung
ich bin nach richtig schön zumal thomas
to myself to buy sell
ja wie gesagt wenn ihr den youtube orten
wollt dann macht der blogger aus wenn
ich es nicht machen wollt dann macht es
halt nicht aber dann beschwert euch
nicht das ist ein gutes thema weil das
sehe ich nämlich auch dadurch dass leute
den etwa garn haben kriegen youtuber
natürlich weniger geld so einfach ist
das und für manche leute ist das
vielleicht auch so ein grund zu sagen
ich will doch nicht dass der youtuber
geld verdienen mit dem was er tut
sie setzt sich dahin und isst kuchen den
soll sie mal schön selber bezahlen zwar
lustig ich bin richtig lustig aber dann
wundert euch nicht oder die leute nie
den etwas anhaben und so dann wundern
sollten sie sich nicht wundern dass
dieses klick bett und so total ausartet
warum blickten die leute weil die halt
ihre miete zahlen müssen
und wenn sie videos machen mit normalen
titeln oder mit mit thumbnails die halt
neutral sind dann kriegen die halt
weniger aufrufe manchmal die hälfte von
denen aufrufen die sie kriegen würden
wenn da hat steht
ich bin fast an kuchen als stick- und da
der entlocken ist bei vielen kriegt man
halt nur ein teil von dem ist okay kann
man machen definitiv machten ihr wollt
es halt nur von unserer sicht aus blöd
kann man immer sagen ich weiß aber auch
dass es da viele gibt unter euch die
super supporten die den adblocker
ausmachen
die einfach ja auch ein bisschen das
wertschätzen was man tut ich habe vorhin
getwittert vorhin heute morgen ich
gehört dass man nicht sich hatte solche
twittert genau dass es leute gibt die
intensiv youtube schauen und auch
liebherr verfolgen und am ende des tages
sagen das ist aber kein richtiger job
oder das ist kein job so
ich finde wenn man zum beispiel
außenstehende ist gar nichts mit youtube
am hut hat und diese welt überhaupt
nicht versteht die wir hier haben dann
kann man gerne sagen das ist kein job
schaut man sich denn da an aber wenn du
dich auf youtube rumtreibt und youtube
verfolgt selbst wenn du nur hast also
hält watching nur die angriffs- und es
alles hat was andere machen
naja dann dann kriegst du ja also dann
beim bisher in dieser welt und die leute
können es ja nicht immer nur in ihrer
freizeit machen und für manche ja da ist
es ein ganz normaler job weil da sich
leute sind die daran auch interesse
haben wir beim kunden punkten
damals hatte charles habe ich den faden
verloren meinte hat vor den absatz
[Musik]
ja das ist meine meinung dazu macht euch
nicht alle fertig das wird schon wieder
youtube wird nicht untergehen
und noch ein punkt zu meiner erfahrung
auf jedem spiel adam und
ein punkt zu meiner erfahrung seit ich
meinen kanal habe habe ich zigtausend
daraus gemacht neue abos natürlich auch
dazu deswegen habe ich jetzt über
200.000 autos
aber ich habe das seit ungefähr einem
jahr dass wenn ich ein video hochladen
das automatisch leute die abonnieren und
das muss nicht immer nur der algorithmus
sein oder youtube ist kaputt es kann
halt auch sein dass mein video auftaucht
und sich dann da jemand sitzt und sich
entweder denkt die habe ich noch
abonnieren die interessiert mich ja gar
nicht also weg damit
oder es gibt halt leute die sich denn
das neue millionen schon denken so was
macht die denn jetzt so die isst kuchen
ich habe die damals abonniert weil die
parodien macht und youtuber verarscht
hat
ich will jedoch nicht beim gucken zu ich
will jedoch nicht beim kuchenessen zu
gucken und dann durch die halt auch
sofort auf den abonnieren
das hat nicht immer nur was mit youtube
zu tun also ich habe das seit seiten ja
wenn ich videos hochladen geht erst mal
so ein paar runter und dann geht halt
wieder normal weiter sodass dieses
wachstum der sogenannte wachstum wie
gesagt nein dieses gute stück ist
riesengroß und ich schaffe es
wahrscheinlich nicht gleich laufe ich im
kreis ich bin voll happy dass ich so gut
gefallen hat das letzte mal also diese
marken videos inhalt keine videos dazu
irgendwie viral gehen oder die zum mega
aufwendig sind und wo hoffentlich sehen
dass so viele leute wie möglich
ich bin happy wenn so ein paar leute aus
meiner community einfach das feiern mal
so ein bisschen ruhiger mich zu erleben
ein bisschen entspannt da mal meinung
von mir zu hören zu sachen die nicht so
sind also flugbahn ja ja ja ja
[Musik]
diese schwarzen haare fancy as [ __ ] ja
gut
der kuchen ich hab kein stück mehr
dass er sich dann später auf wenn ich
nicht an einem zuckerschock gestorben
bin schon vorher
sie geht das hier ist ein richtiger rand
okay ich knall jetzt erst mal 23 werbung
auf dieses video
denn ist es in 14 minuten nicht kann
sich machen und dann überweist die
betreuer ganzes geld an folgende adresse
und der kunden bezahlt ja nicht von
alleine das wisst ihr ja bevor ich jetzt
hier noch weitere blüten rede würde ich
sagen dass wir uns bei meinem nächsten
video wiedersehen
was auch immer das sein wird es passiert
noch ganz viel rate euch meine augen auf
einen offen zu lassen eure herzen offen
zu lassen denn im september lade ich
noch ein paar lustige videos hoch die
sind schon in planung und manche sind
schon gedreht
als es schon gedreht bis dann ist das
viel kuchen gewesen
und jetzt noch das thumbnail das video
heiß ich ersticke an kuchen
bis dann
tschüss